Oh i'm not gonna kill you i'm just
gonna hurt you really really bad
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is gonna
be my video for the new justice league snyder cut
joker announcement that's right jared leto's joker
is coming back in the justice league snyder cut so
i'll explain what's going on what that means and
what the scenes that they're filming with him are
going to be if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos there's a bunch
of really big stuff coming up but starting with
the big stuff first number five if you didn't see
the news just a little while ago i was actually
making a batman video completely unrelated when
they dropped the news that jared leto was coming
back as the joker if that sounds confusing don't
worry because we have the joaquin phoenix joker
and then we have matt reeves new robert pattinson
batman movies that are going to cast their own
version of a new joker once they eventually
get to that character in the sequels so if you
thought there were a lot of batman going around
between ben affleck's batman michael keaton's
batman coming back and the robert pattinson
batman now we're gonna have a whole bunch of
jokers flying around so just to be clear these
are totally new joker scenes that they're filming
during the snyder cut reshoots that are happening
this month so zack snyder is working on a bunch
of stuff he has the new dawn of the dead movie
that he's making right now and they're filming
with some of the justice league actors coming
back like ben affleck's batman is coming back to
film some new scenes wonder woman is coming back
cyborg is coming back because there's a ton of
cyborg that'll be in the snyder cut that wasn't in
the theatrical cut also when they were announcing
jared leto coming back to film new scenes as joker
they said that amber heard is coming back to
film new mira scenes as part of all the atlantis
aquaman stuff that's happening during the movie
the funny part though about the joker news is
that it's completely new stuff that was never part
of the original plan for the justice league movie
when zack snyder was still originally working on
it back in 2017 before he had to leave now what
it seems like is happening with the snyder cut is
that zack snyder is going way above and beyond his
original justice league plan and sort of combining
elements of the original version of justice league
with his plans for justice league 2 had he gotten
to make that movie the snyder cut is going to be
over 4 hours long so they're just using it to wrap
up as many big story lines as possible in payoff
moments that zack snyder had originally probably
intended to pay off in other separate movies that
aren't going to happen now i've also seen a lot of
speculation online since the news broke that this
news of joker coming back is somehow related to
david ayer's suicide squad cut that has a thousand
percent more joker scenes in it that no one has
seen before i'll address that during the video too
before most of you who saw the justice league
snyder cut trailer will remember we already saw
a big joker easter egg in that new footage during
the longer version of the batman nightmare scene
where the camera is panning through the rubble of
the hall of justice formerly known as wayne manor
you can see a bunch of justice league artifacts
weapons trophies from their adventures because
the scene is supposed to be happening years in the
future after dark side has conquered earth that's
what the omega symbol burned into the ground is
for that's what all the ships in the background
are doing here they're strip mining earth for all
of its resources if you want to see the darkest
timeline version of that they did that during
the justice league apocalypse war animated movie
but because this is all happening in the future
the justice league has been together for several
years before this all happened so you see wonder
woman shield you see the picture of batman's
parents there's a ton of stuff here if you zoom
in enhance you also see in the background here
one of joker's playing cards blowing in the
wind implying that at some point batman had
finally defeated the joker not confirming that he
was dead so there already was some kind of joker
stuff happening in the movie but number three most
of the news outlets are describing this new joker
stuff the reshoots as being scenes for the joker
and batman to explain all the dead robin stuff
and pay off the costume from batman v superman
that he walks by the dead robin costume a couple
years ago after the movie came out zack snyder
actually kind of explained what was going on with
this robin because people are like wait a minute
have they already done batman death in the family
are they getting ready for an under the red hood
movie will they introduce a version of jason todd
zack snyder actually clarified that this was meant
to be the grayson robin who had died so obviously
a very different version if they were ever going
to build up to an under the red hood movie there
is a version of a nightwing movie that they were
planning on making a couple years ago but i think
they put that on permanent hold while they're
working on the new robert pattinson matt reeves
batman movies so maybe someday we'll see that
nightwing movie but originally there weren't any
plans to pay off that dead robin scene during the
justice league theatrical cut that zack snyder was
working on way back in 2017 it is possible that
snyder had intended to pay that off in justice
league 2 with some sort of flashback scene because
batman was supposed to die in justice league 2. as
part of that original storyline it was meant to
be sort of a reverse sacrifice twist mirroring
superman's sacrifice in batman v superman superman
died for our sins in batman v superman then in
justice league 2 was supposed to be batman's
turn because of the way things went down and
the way they changed their movie plans and then us
getting avengers infinity war in avengers end game
a lot of people were making marvel comparisons
i don't think that anybody was trying to copy
anyone else but the movies would have felt very
similar with the time travel twists in justice
league and justice league 2 is all the time travel
stuff they did in avengers end game and then iron
man sacrificing himself so you would have had two
giant franchises that felt very similar to each
other but way back when they were still originally
planning on doing justice league 2 with zack
snyder they were still going to do ben affleck's
version of the batman movie that would have taken
place after justice league 2 so during that
version of events is assumed that batman would
have died earlier in the movie than the flash
would have successfully time traveled from this
future post-apocalyptic wasteland warning batman
in the past paying off the batman v superman flash
nightmare scene they do things differently save
superman from darkseid's influence by rescuing
lois lane she would have been killed by darkseid
in the original timeline then they go on to defeat
darkseid and everyone gets their happy ending
going off to their own spin-off movies but number
two though here's the thing the jared leto joker
wasn't originally going to be the main villain
of ben affleck's version of the batman movie that
was supposed to be deathstroke joe manginello said
that originally this deathstroke post credit scene
during justice league was supposed to set up the
batman movie but they changed it when joss whedon
came on so we might see the original version
setting up ben affleck's batman movie when we get
the snyder cut but even if he wasn't going to be
one of the main villains during his version of
the batman movie i think they would still had a
version of jared leto's joker show up during that
it would be weird to have a big batman movie right
after suicide squad and justice league 2 without
seeing the joker show up somewhere in it he was
a huge part of the suicide squad movie before all
the cut downs but he still wasn't a main character
during that they were still originally planning
for him to go off and have a bigger role in
other dc movies though like you sign a big actor
like jared leto you intend to feature him heavily
in at least one movie in most of his appearances
thus far had just been really small cameos
so i think had things gone to their original plan
they would have continued to do suicide squad
sequels with that cast of characters and he would
have continued to show up during those movies
they are doing james gunn's suicide squad movie
but he already said that jared leto's joker isn't
featured anywhere in that even though they're
bringing harley quinn back his movie is also
not supposed to be a direct sequel but it's kind
of a sequel they'll explain what's going on with
the timeline and the continuity at the beginning
of it so don't worry it'll all make sense some of
the cast of the original suicide squad movie is
coming back for the new movie so technically they
are connected but the other big geraldo joker
movies i believe that they had planned to do
were just more harley quinn joker spin-off movies
from suicide squad like imagine the birds of prey
movie if they had done it as a gotham city sirens
movie and joker would have been the main villain
instead of what we actually got in birds of prey
where he was more of a footnote that was supposed
to be his version of the joker at the beginning
of the movie and they didn't even use any geraldo
joker footage it was just supposed to take place
a little while after the events of the original
suicide squad movie but before the events of
the new suicide squad movie so number one just
addressing the david a or suicide squad cut in
the future of the joker character inside the dc eu
right now david ayer does say that there is a
version of an a or cut as he's calling it ready
to go originally what happened is the studio just
took the movie away from him and had someone else
cut a version that they released theatrically
so yes they could do the same thing that they're
doing with the justice league snyder cut and
release it on hbo max in a couple years but the
reason why i don't think they're gonna do that is
mostly because the new suicide squad movie exists
and it's coming out next year in theaters if you
can believe it there's supposed to be some movies
coming out in theaters next year if we didn't have
that new suicide squad movie i'd say probably yes
then they would totally roll out an air cut in a
couple years but now probably not so much as for
the future of the joker character in the dceu or
the dc movies however you want to think about them
i think unless a new director comes in and
wants to specifically use jared leto's joker
or reference him as part of a new harley quinn's
story the next time we see a version of the joker
after the snyder cup will be the new version that
matt reeves casts inside the robber patins and
batman movie trilogy but the joker isn't supposed
to be introduced in a big way until those sequels
at some point he's not meant to be a huge thing in
the first new batman movie he is supposed to exist
in this universe that they're creating you saw
the superman costume behind the scenes you saw the
wonder woman costume so some of the justice league
characters do exist within the universe of robert
pattinson's batman movie but i don't think we're
supposed to see the actual joker of that universe
for a good long while and because they're filming
the movie right now people spotted an easter egg
on the set of that that tells us exactly when
the batman movie takes place in the timeline
recently spotted in chicago where they're filming
gotham city scenes this custom date sticker says
2019 meaning the movie takes place in present day
pretty much but on a different earth i know a lot
of you are also asking now because in a couple
years we'll have three versions of the joker
why don't they just do a three jokers dc black
label movie but post all your joker snyder cut
theories in the comments below what kind of scenes
do you think he's going to have do you think
they'll just be flashback scenes or do you think
we'll see him in present day too real big reminder
the mandalorian season 2 episodes are starting
next week on disney plus i'll be doing videos
for all those as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all those videos
while you wait for everything click here for
that brand new michael keaton batman clip
and click here for all that new robert pattinson
batman footage from the set of the batman movie
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!